in the grand tradition of the common San
Diego theme song that pentatonics video
the hair the police academy guide comes
the best film of all time about making
noises with your mouth pitch perfect
meet Becca a snarky pretentious wannabe
DJ who hates are dead for paying her
tuition you're going to get a college
education first for free
I can't hates this cute guy for flirting
with her
I don't need your help okay can you back
off hates these girls for asking her to
join their club he's paying all of the
world and we compete national
championships on purpose hate your job
we're making her do any work this sucks
who wanted to play music and hates
movies all of them what the hell is
wrong with you I do not like movies
she'll be pressured into joining the
Barden Bellas a down on its luck
acapella group full of one-dimensional
stereotypes lie the sludge I have a lot
of sex the lesbian it started when I
broke up with my girlfriend whoa there
it is the me girl could you please get
your head out of your ass it's not a hat
the kooky border Hey
and the fat one but if you think it's
mean-spirited and lazy to laugh at a
girl for being fat don't worry she does
it to herself so it's totally okay
what's her name
fat Amy horizontal running gonna finish
you like a cheesecake don't put me down
for cardio my real name is fat Patricia
get it she's fat
travel to a fantasy version of college
where everyone gets giant luxurious dorm
rooms and no one goes to class where the
students actually like and respect
acapella groups we are singing acapella
leads to fame and success John Mayer
just asked me to sing backup one time we
sing backup pen and acapella is so
popular it sells out giant venues with
two full-time commentators four judges
and an audience of people who are losing
their just to be there you know what
would make this your better instruments
so laughs along with some surprisingly
funny moments then cringe at a script so
acha full of forced in occupies you want
to akka punch someone in the face you
get rid of all the ARCA politics
my fellow aqua people we're gonna have
our children hands innaka how
about that leave it oh god no akka
awesome I'll kiss use me excuse me
excuse me
okay oh I can uh I can stop it naca
great you've got me akka doing it acha
acha story
I mean starring Anna Kendrick Lamar The
Exorcist the guy your girlfriend likes
the guy your boyfriend likes Rick Tama
Effie Trinket Christopher guest star
and reversible Karthi mean Gleeks ouch
that was so harsh guys but I will say it
definitely could have used more Flula no
wait didn't cinema since already do this
video like a week ago
tardy to the party screen junkies be
sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers what is going on in here
breakfast fine I'll do it myself
shikaka I'm a sexy cat from buckets jar
jar binks made the Star Wars movie worth
watching if I have to read one more of
these comments out loud I just might
lose it